here we will learn to distinguish  between vectors and scalars vectors are  objects that have both a magnitude a  single number and direction whereas  scalars have only a magnitude let's see  some examples of each the length of  something is a scalar because it's just  the magnitude a force exerted by someone  pulling something is a vector because we  care about the strength of the force the  magnitude and the direction in which the  force is acting temperature it's a  scalar if we display temperature on a  weather map where the value of the  temperature is different at each point  in space this is a scalar field in  comparison this weather map of wind or  the value of the wind velocity at each  point in space is represented by a  vector is a vector field